what will the third part of James
Cameron's successful film series look
like a first impression is now provided
by the latest concept images as we
already know Avatar 3 is focused on new
worlds following the recent emphasis on
the gigantic oceans this time we can
expect the exact opposite with a Barren
desert region whereas the snow-covered
landscape that has been teased is likely
to be particularly cold and finally the
volcanic region shown here surely has a
special meaning this is the home of the
so-called Ash people who will play a
major part in the upcoming film
alongside the previously introduced Navi
even though not a lot is visible of the
people yet the images of the three new
regions offer a first preview of what's
to come the new variety of Landscapes is
supposed to show that Pandora just like
Earth has many different peoples and
areas we are excited to learn more about
the Avatar 3 project in the coming weeks
and months the theatrical release is
scheduled for December 20th 2021